secretary robert generic joins me now
good morning to you so the eu stops
short
of an export ban to the uk can you
therefore assure people
that they will get their vaccinations on
time in this country
yes i can we are on course to meet both
of our targets that
all the over 50s and those with clinical
vulnerabilities
will be vaccinated at least with their
first jab by the middle of april
and that all adults will get their
vaccination
by the end of july we've got line of
sight we know we've got the supplies
ahead to deliver on those two critical
targets
but look we are continuing to talk to
our partners
in the european union none of us want to
see any harm to international supply
chains
we've got to work together and cooperate
to ensure that we can get the vaccine
and we can have a win-win situation for
both the uk
and the european union ursula von de
lyon says she hasn't seen any vaccines
exported from
the uk have we exported any vaccines
well vaccines are based on complex
international supply chains
there are elements of the vaccines being
produced in the uk there are elements
being produced in parts of the european
union
and indeed all over the world we're
working with the serum institute for
example
uh in india so it is a critical
for all countries that there are free
flow of medical products including
vaccines across
international borders and it would be
very damaging if
countries started to pull up drawbridges
and prevent
vaccines medicines or elements of them
crossing
international borders and the uk
strongly strongly
opposes that would the uk ever consider
blocking vaccines to the eu though if
they decided to
have an export ban well i'm not going to
get into
that kind of talk i think that's
unhelpful we will continue to discuss
the situation with the european union to
encourage them
to stick to the very clear commitments
that they gave
just a few weeks ago which were that
existing contractual
obligations will be honored that
vaccines and
other medicines can cross borders
unhindered
that's absolutely critical and of course
we'll continue working
with the fantastic manufacturers like
astrazeneca that deserve our support
in light of all that they're doing to
produce vaccines
protect us from the virus and help us to
move forward
you mentioned a short while ago india
the largest
producer of vaccines in the world they
are not going to be exporting vaccines
to us for at least
two to three months we're told surely
that is going to have some bearing on
our supply
well we've built an infrastructure in
this country which really is
world-class it would enable us to
vaccinate even more people than we have
done
in recent weeks millions more people and
so the more
vaccines we can secure the more jabs can
go into people's arms
but we do have enough supply
in sight to continue to meet our
obligations so that means that
if you have an appointment for your
second job you should not be worried
that will be honored you will get that
jab on the date that you were provided
and we will meet those two critical
targets as i said the 15th of april
for the over 50s plus the clinically
extremely vulnerable
and the rest of the population the adult
population
by the end of july and so we'll continue
to be one
if not the leading country in the world
for the vaccine
rollout but if we can secure more supply
and we're confident that we will do
incidentally uh in the months ahead then
we can continue to increase the pace
uh which is critical because the vaccine
at the end of the day is
our route out of this situation uh let's
move on to this um
program to support vulnerable families
um
how is it going to to factor in the the
pandemic you're
saying that 165 million pounds is going
to be
assigned to this well we've for many
years been working with
families through a program that's well
known called
troubled families and today we're
deciding to
recreate that program renew it and
refresh it in light of the pandemic and
it's going to be called supporting
families and it aims to bring together
all of the different agencies of
government
from schools local councils the nhs
gps to support families as a unit
and make sure that they have the wrap
around care and support that they need
to tackle many different challenges as
we come out of the pandemic
ensuring that fewer children go into
care that more children can stay in
school and thrive
as they go back to face-to-face teaching
that we look after people's health
including their mental health and we
help more people back into
the workplace i think this sort of
program has never
been more important and so it's right
that we invest in it
and we're aiming to directly support at
least 69
000 families this year uh potentially
far
more than that and ensure that those
families get the care the support and
the guidance that they need
to thrive in the months and years ahead
can i just ask you about the uh batley
grammar school and the incident there
what was the teacher right
to show a cartoon of the prophet
muhammad to children
well i i don't know precisely what the
teacher
did in the classroom we know that the
school is
looking into the matter and investigator
and that's absolutely right the
department for education
is liaising with the school and with the
local council
what i can say is that there has to be
an appropriate balance
we have to ensure that there is free
speech
that teachers can teach uninhibited but
that has to be done in a respectful and
tolerant way and that's
a balance that's to be struck by
teaching professionals
and by the schools concerned what i
would also
add is that i was disturbed to see
scenes of
people protesting outside the school
that is not right
we shouldn't have teachers members of
the staff of schools feeling intimidated
and the reports that
a teacher may even be in hiding is very
disturbing
that is not a road that we want to go
down in this country so i would strongly
urge people who are concerned about this
issue
not to do that